سر الموائد الفرنسيه يكرم بالعالميه لحظه
كانوا بانتظرها يتجاوزوا هذا الخبز حدود
الموائد الى ليونسكو يعلو الباجيت الفرنسي
بثقافته الطويله ليفرض ضمن قائمه التراث
الثقافيه العالمي غير المادي
عندما يكون الطفل في مرحله السنتين يعطيه
والده راسا من الرغيف الفرنسي ليتناوله
وعندما يكبر الطفل فان اول مهمه يقوم بها
بمفرده هي الذهاب وشراء الرغيف الفرنسيه
بالنسبه لكبارنا فان شراء خبز الباجيات هو
وسيله الاتصال الاجتماعي اليوميه الوحيده
لهم
تتصور رموزه هنا لا يقل احدهما عن الاخر
كلاهما للفرنسيه ما يدل على التاريخ اما
للباجيت حكايه صناعه عمرها اكثر من 100
عاما تصنع بحب حديث بينها وبين خبزها
فل صوتها دلائل على مذاقاتها العديده
صفحات فرنسيه لا تخلو من الباكيت طقوس
يوميه لصناعتها ايضا تضم نحو 6
تقليديه لاكثر من 130 دوله فلكل خباز
لمسته الخاصه
الباقيت تعني العصا والرشاقتي هذه تاريخ
ومعنى ايضا نعود هنا الى فتره نابليون
بونابرت اجتمعت الروايات على ان خابزين
جاؤوا بفكره تطويل الرغيف لتسهيل حمله على
جنود الجيش لتحافظ على مذاقها وشكلها الى
يومنا هذا بل لتتوج بطبع ثقافيه وعالمي
بنكهه البساطه هذه المره غذاء السالم
العربيه